paws with patrol kicked off today at  bruce trent park metro police hosted the  event with food trucks dog adoptions and  pet friendly activities mcgruff was even  around to take a few photos those we  spoke with today said they had a doggone  fun time  i think it's a great family event and so  much interaction with the dogs and i'm  seeing young pups that are being  interacted early  i love the community service like the  police being here and  officer cookie with his little dog oreo  and lots of services  love officer oreo well petco the animal  foundation and three dog bakery bon  appetit along with many others also  helped sponsor the event